[Music]
[Applause]
all of my favorite
kate hudson just covered ariana grande's
seven rings and ari freaking loved it
you heard it here first
it all went down on monday night during
the season finale of nbc's that's my jam
when the 42 year old actress was tasked
with covering the grammy winner's hit
track seven rings
but with a doo-wop twist
watch out world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
impressive right i don't want to cry on
entertainment tonight well ari thought
so too oh my god
because when kate shared a clip from the
show to instagram the god is a woman
singer swooped into the comments
praising her performance not once but
twice writing quote stunning perfect
gorgeous adding may we have this on all
streaming services please
no but like really
can we be
[Applause]
[Music]
and ari wasn't the only celeb to chime
in that's just amazing drew barrymore
octavia spencer dwyane wade and rita
wilson all showed their love in the
comments too
i love them
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel zoe slid in the comments as well
writing this is beyond kate hudson
please please just make an album been
asking for decades
it was a blast of course kate showed off
her vocals back in 2008 on rachel's
reality show the rachel zoe project
covering fleetwood mac
i said i loved you years ago
tell myself you never left me
no
oh i just got chills me too rachel
me too
but back to ari the songbird was a
contestant on that's my jam back in
november and totally brought the house
down alongside her fellow coach on the
voice kelly clarkson
[Music]
yeah that's the thank you next singer
belting out britney spears with kelly
covering shania twain it was like so
crazy but it didn't stop there ari did
her best version of shares believe
[Music]
and kelly totally crushed elena's more
sets you oughta know
[Applause]
[Music]
and if you thought that was impressive
just listen to the powerhouse singers
covering whitney houston and tony
braxton respectively
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know whose voice i like best ari
kelly or kate but one thing's for sure
these ladies can sing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you